driverless taxi company Cruz has had a
bumpy month its autonomous driving
permits were suspended in California
after a woman was dragged 20 ft under
one of its Vehicles the company then
paused operations in every single one of
its us markets to focus on rebuilding
public trust and that could be a
challenge see as driverless companies
try to increase public acceptance of
their Tech they're rolling out more and
more Vehicles onto public roads but that
increases the probability that one of
these cars could have an accident that
damages the paintwork and the reput of
the technology while every safe journey
may be one step forward every Collision
can be two steps back a recent AAA study
found that the number of Americans
afraid of self-driving technology has
actually increased so how can driverless
car companies rebuild trust after a
crash okay so in case you missed it
here's how Cruz lost its permits in
California on October 2nd at around 9:30
p.m. on the corner of Fifth and Market
Street in San Francisco a pedestrian was
hit by a car not the cruise one and fell
into the path of a driverless Cruise
vehicle the creu vehicle breaked hard
and stopped and then attempted to pull
over to the side of the road the problem
was that The Pedestrian who was struck
was actually still under the cruise
vehicle and according to the DMV was
pulled 20 ft forwards of speeds of up to
7 mph the DMV said this may have caused
further injury to The Pedestrian now
Cruz said it spoke to the DMV about the
incident but the DMV said Cruz didn't
mention that the vehicle had attempted
to pull over Cruz however said it showed
the DMV a full video of the incident
California's DMV then suspended
Cruiser's driverless license to carry
paying passengers and crucially it's
licensed to test on public roads saying
the manufacturers vehicles are not safe
for the Public's operation so if Cruz
isn't allowed to be conducting
driverless operations on roads in
California how can it rebuild trust it's
particularly important that the company
does figure out a way just because
California is its biggest Market that's
wsj's Autos reporter Ryan Felton you're
not going to ever feel that it's safe
until you actually experience it it's
hard to imagine what other sort of
scenarios exist to kind of rebuild that
trust other than just seeing through
that people you know experience it with
its licenses revoked in California Cruz
may have to turn to the other states it
was operating in to get back out there
and demonstrate that its technology can
be safe in the real world but there is
still a path for the company to resume
driverless operations in California the
DMV has sort of spelled out to the
company it says steps it can take to get
back on the road get its permit we don't
know what those steps are at this point
but the fact that the DMV is regulating
this industry and revoking real licenses
from real Robo taxis in the real world
when they have real safety issues is a
sign that driverless technology is in
some way finally real like it's it's
happening and barring some sort of like
fulls scale pullback across like the US
which seems highly unlikely like this is
happening there's mechanisms in place to
kind of take action when something does
happen and I think that's what you're
seeing now Cru isn't the only driverless
car company operating in the US and
while it has been experiencing setbacks
others have been making Headway
alphabet's weo for example recently
expanded its operations across San
Francisco and announced that it was
offering rides through Uber's platform
in Phoenix but setbacks for one company
can have impacts on the reputation of
the technology as a whole and what's not
clear is how much further driverless
technology will have to go to convince
the majority of the public that it's
safe or how many accidents will happen
along the way L's May recently wrote to
the president of California's Public
Utilities Commission to voice serious
concerns about a decision to approve an
autonomous vehicle program in the city
and there are still those who believe
that Cruz has rolled out its technology
on public roads too quickly Cruz for its
part has since announced that they're
taking a number of steps to improve how
the company operates including issuing a
voluntary software recall the vast
majority of things aren't 100% foolproof
that is just the reality here that we're
at a point now where there are companies
actually using this technology actually
commercializing it there's going to be
incidents that happen just like if a
driver a human driver gets into a crash
there there could be ramifications as
well so while Crews might not be
operating autonomously on Californian
roads in the near future the October 2nd
incident is unlikely to be the last
incident that an autonomous vehicle
experiences on its road to building
public
Trust